oh uh what do you take for this almond
milk
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Chelsea Handler a
hot [ __ ] whoa whoa Sally she's one of
the world's most successful TV hosts a
writer producer actress and New York
Times bestselling author many times over
speaking of her latest book life will be
the death of me in you two is set to
release on April 9th followed by 20 to
date comedy tour Chelsea Handler welcome
to the show
thank you very much thank you for having
me I appreciate you coming in I have a
bad history with chicken wings so I
wanted to come and kind of face it I
mean I like spicy but I mean I don't I
don't know what's gonna happen now here
I mean I don't know what kind of you
know [ __ ] you're gonna throw at me but
I'm ready for it
[Music]
[Music]
okay that's good
spicy very light mm-hmm
[Music]
so comedy that's full of bizarre origin
stories but never heard of anyone who
got their start at DUI class how did
that click for you like did getting big
laughs in the classroom give you the
confidence to try stand-up yes I got a
DUI when I was 21 and that scared me
straight and I haven't ever had to do I
sense but my punishment I had to go to
this DUI school where they you go one
night a week and they teach you how to
avoid getting more DUIs but the
avoidance isn't really necessarily to
stop drinking it's like what you say to
a cop when you get pulled over and I'm
like these are they're enabling us to
get like to just keep drinking and
driving a not get caught and then
everyone at some point had to get up and
tell their story and I was like [ __ ]
that I didn't want to publicly speak I
was so embarrassed finally on the very
last day he's like get up and tell your
story and I started telling everybody
the story about how I called the copper
racist we were both white I had my
sisters ID that I was like using so I've
gotten even more trouble and it went
great like people started laughing and
they were howling and I didn't get off
the stage I'm like this is [ __ ] fun
and then people like you should do
stand-up and that's how I got the guts
to do it
yeah I mean it's good this is definitely
a lot spicier than the one before in
your series Chelsea does there's an
episode where you eat this six course
marijuana infused meal is that the
trickiest dinner experience you've ever
had or does the crown still go to that
Taco Bell run you did on mushrooms with
large Luke thank you for bringing that
up and I know that's from one of my
books I said I spend a lot I mean the
marijuana infused dinner those are
tricky because you're high for like
three or four [ __ ] days
I don't I mean I woke up the next day
and I had to shoot something and I
wasn't right like I wasn't it right in
the head for a while and your eyes are
like half-caste you know you're just
like kind of not fully awake um and I
once had a marijuana facial accidentally
I didn't request it the woman just
assumed I wanted one and she wasn't
wrong but I wasn't right after that so
there's something about marijuana
putting it in your system like when it's
I'm poor is different it is different so
the facial and the edibles the meal of
edibles it was just I overdosed
that's why micro dosing is so important
I think cuz I don't want to feel like
that I want to just have a little you
know take the edge off I'm have
everybody be a little bit less annoying
[Music]
where's this from I went skiing last
week done for Colorado okay speaking of
and I have I got this really bad wind
burn and my lips are really chapped so
this on top of it is exceptional you
know what that is such a poetic segue
into my next question because skiing
it's something that we don't talk about
enough on hot ones and it's something
that you quote [ __ ] love what are the
logistics of taking the chairlift when
you're famous like do you engage in that
chairlift small talk or do you just hide
behind the helmet and the goggles and
hope you make it to the top and
recognize well I was once on a chairlift
and I think I was in Whistler maybe and
I was just going off about this one guy
at lunch she would something and the guy
next to me goes are you Chelsea Handler
he goes I he goes I recognize the way
you say [ __ ] idiot and I was like yes
thank you I am Chelsea Handler I
definitely engage in small talk on share
laughs I like it
and then for a seasoned drinker there
are a few things that hold the romance
of that a press key post jump off the
slope socializing thing can you close
your eyes and describe your ideal a
pristine vironment as
detail as possible yeah a lot of hot men
I like I I want I need it I need a hot
ski guy so this is actually a great
place to say this cuz I am looking for a
boyfriend now I'm ready to be in a
relationship and I think this is the
place to announce it and I think this is
the place to announce it I need somebody
who has a [ __ ] life and is a great
skier okay those are the two things and
I don't want them to be a ski guide I
want them to do skiing in their spare
time and then they have some business
that they're in that's outside of skiing
it could be anything almost anything do
you worry about climate change as it
relates to the shortening ski season or
is that too big an [ __ ] concern to
open with when you're talking about
environmental issues yeah that sounds
like a pretty jackass thing to say I
don't think about climate change with
relation to skiing like this year for
instance is a great ski season
everyone's getting dumped on there's
tons of snow everywhere in the states so
it can work in both ways as you're
getting hotter yeah that's how the game
goes I almost just swallowed my tongue
it went like it jolted back yeah we got
a ways to go yeah my lip is really
burning
[Music]
where's our front yes Long Island so is
the wing from Long Island or is this
from all the sauces are local the wings
we source from throughout the country
okay and how do you source them who's
your source
well are you into is like you just are
the wing lover you've always eaten wings
or is this just you know we just were
trying to solve for a problem which is
like interview shows celebrity interview
shows are boring and how do you make
them not my father
[Music]
do you have a take on the state of
celebrity interview shows like is the
late-night format failing its audience
or is that a position that's a little
overstated
no I think there's an audience I mean
people like that stuff it's just it's
what you're into I don't love
interviewing celebrities you know what I
mean
I've done it for like ten years so it's
not my favorite thing to do I'd rather
talk to a real person do I do
Wow yeah yeah take it however you watch
it I don't like being fake ever so my
problem is like much with a lot of those
interviews you have to be fake and it's
just not my game you haven't had a sip
of your milk not yet not yet I'll feed
you after I'll catch you I'll breast
feed you after it'll be fine
[Music]
some people eat the bones like you I
just took a bite of a bone that's why
I'm Santa I just want to have like other
people do it too I accidentally
masticated a bone I don't know where
we'll share our [ __ ] 8012 all right
I'll see you every Korean segment on our
show called explain that grammar we do a
deep dive and I guess Instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context so I'll bust out the laptop I'll
show you the picture you tell me the
bigger story does that sound good yeah
all right laptop please Ivan had a glass
of milk trance I was like
their first glass of milk in a while its
almond milk so it's kind of like [ __ ]
milk you know what I mean it's not is
this the Miss New Jersey era Chelsey him
well I did Miss Teen New Jersey and they
told me I needed to lose 15 pounds I was
like 14 or 15 so then I lost 15 pounds
as you could tell the [ __ ] picture
and went to this other pageant and the
guy was a total shyster like he screwed
everybody over my parents paid like
three grand to get me in the pageant you
take all these classes and like you know
you have to learn how to dance and have
a talent um do your hair like that and
then there was never any pageant so my
parents got [ __ ] over like fire
festival exactly right and one last fun
though cuz I was with my parents here
you are yelling at a guy for wearing a
robe to a restaurant do you remember
this conference I'm Jim Whistler and a
guy came over and asked me for a picture
with him
and I was like not you're in a
restaurant in a robe excuse me I just
burped you're in a restaurant in a robe
you can't ask me for a picture you're
[ __ ] inappropriate like your balls are
under there and where food is a near
body and look at him trying to defend
himself we took the picture eventually
you folded on that I just said listen
this is your morning I hope I don't see
you again in the south man do more for
you Chelsea what was the most majestic
animal you saw on safari Mary McCormack
and Charlize they're uh and Charlize his
mom and my cousin Molly are in that
picture yes um being on Safari is like
the [ __ ] best experience of ours
that's right up there was skiing without
the activity you could just stare at
those animals for hours it's gorgeous I
mean the elephants and the mat like you
see how big they are and how protective
they are there it's just beautiful hey I
could sit there and watch a lion just
sitting there for like two or three
hours so you know you bring your
cocktails in the car they make you these
little like lunches and you just get
shit-faced while you're like a zoo yeah
it's a nice vibe yeah totally and then
one more for you Chelsea this is a
classic Chelsea Handler thirst trap can
you give me one can you give me can you
give me one time when you were unfairly
targeted by instagrams Community
Guidelines and then one time where you
thought you know
they have a point um I don't know it's
very it's a tricky subject to say that
women aren't allowed to be topless when
you guys can just walk around my house
words everywhere insects yeah why are
our nipples not available like why is it
or not okay for us to be topless because
worse it's sexual like why I was also
coming into my own I had a boyfriend
that made fun of my boobs good for being
too big and when we broke up that's when
I went on my topless rampage because I
had another guy's like these are great
what do you know I'm like you know what
they are great he and my boyfriend I had
for a couple of years was like your
boobs are too big they're not they're
not elegant I'm like elegant so when we
broke up that was my ID up are you yeah
that was my coming-out party and you
know what my tits are [ __ ] awesome
so I'm [ __ ] happy about that
are you eating yours fillet because I
feel like I'm doing more eating than you
are I'll go bite for bite with your
Chelsea competition but I'm just curious
well you did bring it up a semi
confrontational hmm know everything do
you feel challenged everything I say is
sort of semi confrontational and I don't
even mean it I don't know why people
like when people say oh you're such a
[ __ ] or you're you know intimidating or
I'm scared of you like what are you
talking about I listen to you talk I get
it now
I prefer myself talk I understand when
you left Chelsea Lately one of the notes
that you went out on was that you were
happy to not have to worry about what
the Kardashians were doing from time to
time or know every headline and the
tabloids but I'm curious now do you
experience some of the same burn out
with this 24-hour news cycle every day
is Armageddon thing I hate it but there
is a steady diet of news I think it's
reading the news being informed so
you're not an idiot like I don't want to
be uninformed I want to know what's
going on but I don't want to be angry
all day right so and I know I have the
tools to do that I got up I meditate I
meditate on headspace I've never been
like I was like [ __ ] meditation I'm so
sick of people talking about mindfulness
meditation cut to which was more of a
Viper's nest to navigate PC culture of
the 2000s versus you know this like
Twitter woke era okay the same thing or
is there distinguishable well I mean
right now we're in a PC phase too you
know everybody yes with me too and times
up like everyone wants to be an ally and
an advocate to or not everybody does but
I mean you know mostly people in
Hollywood are trying to do the right
thing and it's like you're it's tricky
you don't want to say the wrong I just
filmed a documentary for Netflix on
white privilege and you don't you know I
offended a million people are filming
that every day I was getting into
trouble by asking hard questions but
instead of looking at it as a hindrance
it's just I try to look at it as getting
a better understanding we're in a period
of over correction I think and hope
because we have to correct the behavior
right so it goes hard to eventually got
to get the car yeah I mean I'd like to
be able to hit on guys at work you know
what I mean so I'm hoping that we can
all figure this out soon
I like garlic a lot it's too bad oh
that's hot
mm-hmm it's not pleasant hot either it's
like it's offensive the garlic's not
saving it for you no no no it's like a
hurts mine roof of my mouth I'll finish
it though
do I have to finish it you win you know
you don't have to what are the rules
here I'd like some rules I like the
parameters yeah so I want it to be like
the most uncomfortable comfortable
interview ha ha that being said if you
like rules people seem to respect the
people who go hard on the wings you know
is that right thank you for the people
yeah it's burning yeah
in your book life will be sorry sorry I
trouble you again how do you like I'm
directing this I like it I like it take
the wheel take the wheel
take the wheel Chelsea mmm so in your
book life will be the death of me you
pull back the curtain on this year-long
self exploration first things first is
the cover photoshopped or your ciaochao
just that well-behaved that they can
just sit there for the photograph no my
dogs don't [ __ ] around they sit there
and it's not photoshopped I mean I'm
sure it's photoshopped on my face and
stuff but not the dogs my dogs are a
little bit of [ __ ] I have two Chows
and they're part child they're part
Rottweiler which I found out when I got
their 23andme done [ __ ] I don't want a
Rottweiler they'll be with me if they
have to but they prefer my cleaning lady
Miguel and so when she leaves every day
at like 4:00 or 5:00 they sit at the
door and stare out the window and then
at 9 or 10 o'clock when I'm going
upstairs to my room I have to put them
both on a [ __ ] leash bring them up to
my room like prisoners and put them in
there did you visit a shaman this year
no I did that a couple of years ago for
a special I did the ayahuasca which I
also wrote about because it was a it was
an awesome experience and I would
recommend it to anybody who can handle
like really hallucinate him what's that
like how is it different than mushrooms
mushrooms are more joyful like laughy in
my experience ayahuasca was more like
you see this fast-forward I pallid
shuffle of your life and you're not in
it like so I saw myself as a little girl
running on the beach with my sister
playing with our dog that I had
forgotten I'm we had his kid like every
memory is real and it's just somewhere
in your psyche and it just lets it out
and it just gives you this overwhelming
kind of you feel loved like it's not
like ecstasy where you want to [ __ ] it's
like you feel Oh
overcome with your emotions for in my
instance it was my sister but a lot of
people feel it for their spouse or their
kid you know I don't have those so I
have to find love somewhere else
[Music]
okay
[Music]
what's this red oh yes is to discus to
specially there's too much this is the
bomb
Oh oh dear yeah yeah this is where
people come on salat yeah why do rappers
make the best talk show guests you know
why
[Music]
it's too spicy that's too spicy it's
wild if you look at our guest list it's
clear that we love hip-hop artists too
but I don't think it's unfair to say
that they are by far the latest guests
does that ever posed a logistical
challenge for you or your crew oh [ __ ]
what do you take for this almond milk
[Music]
is it I can't I'm trying to think about
something else yeah I don't know what to
do
you okay Chelsea yeah I mean I got can I
have some Vaseline it for my lips do we
have any Vaseline in the building
uh but rappers are late yes and I yes I
once had who was at P Diddy mm-hmm he
was three hours late come on in
ah
[Music]
see you in the spice oh [ __ ] uh-huh all
right I'm gonna take a break from the
blings I'm trying to ask you a questions
I'm flooring 50 cent obviously everyone
knows I dated him or maybe some people
don't
my mat would be great but 57 was so late
to my show when I had a mom that he sent
me some because I yelled I didn't want
to got there and I was like you're
that's [ __ ] irresponsible and blah
blah and he sent me flowers every day
and filled up my office with flowers
like hundreds of bouquets of flowers and
finally I was just like I got better
have sex with this guy because I mean
how am I gonna get him to stop
I mean I mean right PJD came to my show
and was so obnoxious in so late and I
went off on him on the show I waited I
didn't see him and I was like I'm gonna
approach this differently cuz I didn't
want to also have to sleep with me Diddy
you know so I waited I just yelled at
him on camera during the interview and
that felt very satisfying oh I don't
know if I can I don't know if I can eat
anymore
yes what happens now if I don't I just
can't handle it and I can't talk so
that's just maybe the goal here to get
me to shut the [ __ ] up like this is like
if you want to get [ __ ] up like this
is what the label should be if you want
to take an edible that's gonna knock you
down it should also look like to bomb
right you know that's where you can't
get mad at it don't eat me it's
basically what the label says what do
you want me to do take another bite I
mean as our communication is really
dwindling I feel here I'm still
connected are you so connected mm-hm I'm
connected to not continuing to eat these
wings but if you need me to I will I
really respect that
and I know that you're at this moment
yeah like well what is that a certain
point yeah I know like Beyonce was with
whatever when was she had a turning
point what was that movie or the song
turn turn turn
I think that was Bonnie Tyler but it's
like you're so close to the top of the
mountain
and then what happens at the mountain I
die at the top of the peak you know I
don't care I don't know there's no real
right and there's no II say oh you could
you'll accomplish something you know
flick liming like I don't know hype
because I don't give a [ __ ] you do that
sometimes
well I hike yeah no I don't think I hike
when did you how do you know what I'm up
to
because you know I do a lot I do a lot
of reading on you know I don't I'm not
into hiking in LA I don't think the
views are that pretty here yeah I'm in
in some great location I'll go hiking
and like South Africa they have this
thing called lions head right and I did
that hike you didn't do that yeah I got
to the top it was a mouthful picture oh
that's where like oh wow yeah really do
your research wow that's interesting
good for you you take your job seriously
oh thank you Chelsea well I mean you're
welcome alright I know
alright I'm just gonna let this one go
right that's fine cuz I tried it and I
don't want to deal with that right let's
move on let's turn the page
I was [ __ ] straight shot it you know
to mean get the chicken again and just
not even deal with you oh well so hot
yeah that's hot mm-hmm a different kind
of hot I don't know what you have
working behind the scenes but there is a
lot of great press about what an amazing
boss you are is it true that when you're
at Chelsea Lately you had setup
scholarship funds for the employees
babies that we worked with I did do that
yeah that's funny
I only hear bad things about myself
really yeah that I'm a [ __ ] you know
that I'm difficult that I'm I don't know
I knew bad things but you always hear
that stuff I don't you know you never
listen to the good stuff or maybe you
just don't hear the good stuff so I'm
glad you brought that up yes I did
[ __ ] get them College was rather
[ __ ] kids do you think that HR
departments focused too much on
discouraging office romances yeah first
of all well there shouldn't be
harassment I think like people should be
allowed to the freedom as adults to
participate in a relationship with each
other also I feel that people if they
need to get high to be at work go for it
as long as you're responsible and you
want to do if you want to have to be you
know have a cocktail in the middle of
the day you should also be able to do
that if you can act responsibly it's
people who abuse a situation and think
that they're in a position of power and
can like harass somebody that's totally
not acceptable and I think a lot of us
doesn't realize how much that was going
on in everywhere in everyone worlds you
know until this whole meets you movement
happens I think it's made us all just
kind of like look at ourselves and say
okay this behavior is not acceptable
you can't touch people on their bodies
it's not received well some people don't
have issue with it and some people do so
you just have to operate on the fact
that everyone's going to take issue with
it and behave yourself
which is why it's a good thing I don't
have a TV show right probably have
lawsuits against me I've never done
anything sexually inappropriate well
that's not true I probably have done
that too
I don't know I'm inappropriate as a
general rule so I just have to keep to
myself for a while
[Music]
all right Chelsea this is actually Tracy
I feel so stupid yeah I know it's Tracy
this is the last dab Tracy we call it
the last dab because it's tradition
around here to put a little extra in the
last wing you don't have to if you don't
want to I'm not doing anything that's
fine
sorry would I see what happened there
yeah yeah interrupt that's good luck
cheers Cheers Chelsey Tracy whatever
your name is alia where I didn't put the
sauce I won't put it be out on the food
just flow out of my mouth I told you
guys I was gonna happen
all right Chelsea Handler here we are at
the end of our journey and we've touched
on a lot today but one thing we haven't
touched on yet is that you're something
of a guru about self-improvement and
you're not an [ __ ] about it and
always committed to the next day turning
the page on dabomb always self-improving
so now that you have the hot sauce
coursing through your veins the death
wings like a truth serum eroding that
already non-existent [ __ ] meter that
Chelsea Handler has can you give the
people out there the viewers a chart a
path to be in an adult-like what's worth
trying and what's not worth wasting your
time with that's funny you mentioned
that because I'm reading this book it's
called essentialism and it's about
getting all the clutter out of your life
and focusing on doing say two things
really great instead of eight things
mediocre so by not doing my show by
taking the year to write a book to film
a documentary I do feel like the quality
has risen and so I would advise anybody
to stop saying yes to everything and
focus on the things that you really want
to excel at for me is being a [ __ ]
badass skier and being a great writer
well if Tracie handler says that then
you know it's the truth and look at you
ten chicken wings up ten chicken wings
down and now there's nothing left to do
but roll out the red carpet for you
Chelsea Handler this camera this camera
this camera let the people know what you
have going on in your life I have a new
book it's called life will be the death
of me and I'm coming to a city near you
I'm doing a sit-down comedy tour with
celebrity guests in each city that will
be interviewing me on stage so you can
get your tickets of Live Nation com
and then I have a documentary coming out
in the summer on Netflix fun ready let's
car Bloods together I would spit this
out but we know what that looks like so
thank you thank you for watching hey
what's going on hot ones fans this is
Sean Evans checking in from the Museum
of curiosities with a very exciting
sauce update if you have not subscribed
to the hot ones monthly subscription box
April is the month to do it why well
first off limited edition sticker but
second because this box is going to have
three hot sauces that have never before
been tasted never been released never
before seen until this month they're all
made by hot sauce makers that have
previously been featured on hot ones
that's right three bottles of hot sauce
no one's ever seen before no one's ever
tasted before no one's ever touched
until you reach into that box and pull
it out and put it on your Caesar chicken
wrap for the very first time that's
April subscription box three bottles
thirty bucks plus a limited edition
sticker who's looking out for you us